foreign
we got Elizabeth from Nashville what's
going on Elizabeth how can we help today
hey guys how are you doing good how are
you
good okay I hopefully have a simple
question
um okay so me and my husband were
talking uh last night about the budget
and we were just we were a little
stumped on on something should we be
saving any of our money just to save
money like we do have some things we'd
like to save for and we're putting money
aside for that but should we be saving
money just to save money are you on baby
step three or baby step one
so we have the emergency fund fifteen
thousand dollars our monthly expenses
are about three we have a thousand
dollars in a separate of fund a separate
fund that like all the bills come out
and we that that thousand is basically
like zero
um we're investing six percent
um and we're only doing that because we
are technically at baby step three B and
we're trying to save somewhere between
fifteen hundred to two twenty five
hundred a month
um for for a down payment cool cool cool
cool cool cool cool very cool
the emergency fund outside of like
thinking funds should we just should we
be saving some money just to save money
well maybe also would it be wrong like
if we had money saved up would it be
wrong to use that money if something
came up when we were like oh I'd like
new kayaks or shoes or something okay
yeah I hear what you're saying
um
so I do want to call out the fact that
you're you guys have got your own system
that you're working
um it's not the baby steps and that's
fine if you want to work whatever system
that you Elizabeth and your husband want
to work but mostly what are we doing
wrong okay I'm glad you asked thank you
for asking hello Elizabeth you shouldn't
have done that no that was good because
if if she he had it it was Choose Your
Own Adventure there for a minute John if
she had chosen to be like what no what
do you mean then we would have been we
would have gotten gotten into it but
Elizabeth is like I want to learn help
me I love it Elizabeth okay so here's
what I'll call out
um you really only need that thousand
dollars saved starting out that's baby
step one your starter emergency fund
that's a barrier between you and life 56
of Americans don't have anything they
can't cover a thousand dollar emergency
so by you just having that thousand
dollars you have set yourself up uh so
far ahead of society so that's thing one
thing two do you guys have debt
no okay baby step two is done number
that's wonderful baby step three it said
that you you said you had 1500 set aside
somewhere oh fifteen thousand
fifteen thousand oh sweet and then you
said you had another fund of a thousand
dollars okay so we're getting there okay
and then three B just like if we have
the thousand in there it's just like a
buffer between like if something happens
and uh we don't want to touch the
emergency fund uh so it's an emergency
fund for your emergency fund
yeah it's that's where all the bills
come out and so like if something
happens I see yeah it's just it's like a
little cushion yeah I'm not gonna yell
it I'm not going to yell at you for that
I'm not I I get it some people do it I
probably wouldn't do it you got fifteen
thousand dollars but I get it I'm not
gonna yell at you about that
um are you guys saving up for a house is
that again I got you yeah that's where
we're at we're at baby step 3B okay so
technically you're not at baby step four
yet so I don't know that I would be
contributing to
you know investing just yet if you're in
3B and you're trying to like
kick this thing out
um I thought Dave said you could do like
a little mix of both you could it just
depends on what what your goals are if
you're trying to hurry up and do this or
not
because I mean technically the baby
steps work in order
um but like if you were a person and you
were already in the house and you're
saving for another house I wouldn't tell
you to stop investing to save for
another house do you see what I'm saying
like I wouldn't have you go backwards in
that way so if you want to do a little
mix of it I'm not mad at that but if
you're trying to move quickly I'd
probably hold up for a minute and walk
the baby steps exactly in order
I hear you you know what I'm saying so
yeah
um can I can I ask you this Elizabeth
what what are you scared it's gonna
happen
what do you mean John you've got you've
got layer on top of layer on top you are
trying to insulate yourself from the
world fortification Maybe
um what are you what are you scares
gonna happen
John I went in debt and I never want to
do it again
okay
having a little cushion let me just say
this in the account that you're paying
your bills from having a line item in
your budget that's like hey no matter
what there's always 500 here no matter
what there's always 200 here I'm not mad
at that I think if it gets excessive it
could be an indicator of possibly
something else so Elizabeth yesterday I
was talking to
um his name is Sal DiStefano he's a good
buddy of mine and he is with the Mind
pump guys in San Jose they are they
basically are doing for the Fitness and
Nutrition industry what Dave is doing
has done for 30 years for the finance
industry I trust the guy and he's
brilliant here's what he told me he said
most
um people fail I think it's up to 90
percent of workouts and diets fail
because people are they don't like what
they see in the mirror so much they are
exercising because they hate themselves
and so exercise becomes a form of
punishment for how I look for how I've
eaten
and what he said is if you go into the
gym to exercise as a form of punishment
you you deserve a hard workout today
because of how you look and how you eat
and how lazy you are and these are these
are all things we're saying to ourselves
that that is gonna fail it's gonna fail
and so what I want to tell you is
you went in the dead you did
and you owned reality and you and your
husband have worked your butts off
I want you at some point to stop
punishing yourself and stop setting up
all these curbs for what if I do it
again because that's not you anymore
and I want you to start going to
something not dragging around this past
and trying to create all these imaginary
buffers for things that for ways you
might do something stupid again that's
not who you are anymore
and go towards something right so when
people go to the gym because they know
they're worth that hour
when they eat right because I know how
good I'm gonna feel tomorrow when I wake
up those people stick to those diets
that's you're talking about identity
change and that's what we're that's
that's that's what I'm talking about
here I want you to give some credit to
my new friend Elizabeth that that
um that that that's your past you've
been there and we're gonna we're gonna
follow these baby steps all the way to
the end and we're gonna wake up
millionaires in a few years
um because we we started going towards
something not we didn't continue to run
from things does that make sense
that's so good Elizabeth you're doing
everything right John I love what you
just said you're you're talking to me on
that Elizabeth he was talking to both of
us on that one now
I appreciate the call hey if you want to
buy Elizabeth if you want to buy kayaks
save up some money and buy some kayaks
go kayaking you're out of baby step two
do a little something something you got
your baby step three done yeah you can
buy organic diapers you can buy kayaks
but get them anyway get them anyway
you can spend a little bit of your money
remember you can give your money you can
save your money uh you can spend your
money and don't forget to have a little
bit of fun with this you know what I'm
saying guys this is the Ramsey Show